it's a new year full of new games and  the latest PlayStation Plus offerings  are here I'm Tony this is a game spot  news update and this is your January  lineup first up the ps4 is getting an  updated classic with day of the tentacle  remastered it's also getting the Indy  action-adventure Titan Souls stealth  titled the swindle and the gritty  survival game this war of mine the  little ones all three of those titles  are also coming to the PS Vita along  with the match 3 game as can to the  world beneath the ps3 is also getting  the swindle along with vehicle combat  game blaze rush sounds like a pretty  good start to 2017 it's Tuesday January  third when this video goes up so these  games should already be on the PSN store  by the time you log in which games are  you picking up let me know in the  comments or on twitter at chain-gun hope  and for all the biggest PlayStation news  you're already in the right place